it's shortly before dawn in the Namibian
desert but the Rhino wardens are already
on the job they set out as early as
possible because temperatures will soon
be up in the 40s Celsius they make the
best progress with donkeys they're out
to protect the last black rhinos living
in the wild here in Africa and to
protect them from poachers they often
spend days out in the heat to find a
rhino other wildlife like lions leopards
and elephants are a danger to us but we
need to find out as much as we can about
the Rhino their numbers their state of
health and behavior patterns in order to
protect them the first success of the
day the team has found a rhino trail the
locals learn how to read tracks at an
early age some of them used to be
poachers themselves forced into it by
poverty now as wardens they get a
regular salary used to poach because we
were hungry for meat not for trading in
rhinos feeding my family by protecting
animals
they carry on for several kilometers on
foot following the Rhino trail in the
distance mountain zebras the animals
have adapted to the harsh conditions in
the Namibian desert suddenly Ghana said
spots what they've been looking for for
just a brief moment before the animal
trots away
the wardens follow the Rhino in order to
count the animals they need photos that
identify them
the Rhino gets wind of the men and
suddenly charges
black rhinos are more aggressive than
other species
this time the wardens remain unharmed
about the new Goliath class car driver
oh we got to close but we need to record
all features and characteristics of the
animals well that information has
already led to the largest rhino data
bank worldwide come on ya have a gift
visitors from all over the world travel
to northwestern Namibia to see the
Rhinos the wardens take care of them and
make sure the animals are left in peace
this group has hit it lucky they're able
to watch a rhino with her young
it's a rare sight the wardens say
poaching is on the increase again that
say the situation is no better in
neighboring South Africa rhino poaching
there is worse than ever
the way it's gang at the moment it's
it's a Daniel slide from what I can
gather as well as we almost hit their
watershed now where the the growth rate
has become negative the the rate of
poaching has outstripped the rate of
births in rhino and
so it's a major problem the wardens in
Namibia are on the alert
sixteen rhinos fell victim to poachers
here last year two of them from the
project area
the trust has now stepped up
surveillance flights Namibia is in
danger of once again becoming a major
target for the Rhino mafia
silicon's they're very powerful they've
got a lot of financial backing and
they're also using people inside the
country inside South Africa and other
African countries to do the dirty work
for them they really powerfully there
aren't enough wardens to cover the huge
region but the Rhino trust in Namibia is
looking for partners that way more
people can keep an eye on the Rhinos and
protect them from poachers